Another thing that Dr. Bright is not allowed
to do at the SCP Foundation: Make up jodies
for Morning Calisthenics, including, of course,
the Mickey Mouse Club House song.
In Military parlance, jodies are a name for
the chants performed while marching to keep
the soldiers in time and boost morale.
These can be extremely helpful for military
marches, but not for the group calisthenics
being performed in the Foundation gym.
Certain employees, who chose to remain anonymous
in their HR Reports, described this as “annoying”
and “distracting”, especially when Dr.
Bright chose to sing the Mickey Mouse Club
House song.
Dr. Clef, who did not wish to remain anonymous,
said, “If I have to hear that stupid song
one more time when I’m trying to get my
morning reps in, I’m shoving that goofy
medallion where the sun don’t shine.”